le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
avant de pouvoir travailler il faut
apprendre pendant toute sa scolarité
on apprend à lire à écrire à l'étudier
et à se concentrer
l'apprentissage est indispensable et
contribuer activement à la réussite
professionnelle mais une réussite
scolaire n'aboutit pas systématiquement
à une embauche car le manque
d'expérience freine les employeurs alors
comment acquérir de l'expérience
professionnelle tout en faisant ses
études on en parle maintenant d'un lien
social
virginie a 21 ans et c'est d'un pas
motivée qu'elle se rend à son travail
depuis quelques mois maintenant son
application et sa détermination font de
cette jeune femme une employée modèle
pourtant virginie n'est pas embauché
définitivement mais fait un contrat
d'apprentissage dans le cadre de son
année d'études
cette année virginie prépare un master
en ressources humaines et organisation
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
un tel niveau d'étude n'est pas
forcément associée à une embauche facile
les employeurs refusent parfois des
embauches avec un prétexte assez
contradictoires sur diplômés mais cette
raison n'est pas la seule car pour
augmenter ses chances d'obtenir un
emploi quel que soit le niveau d'études
mieux vaut avoir de l'expérience
professionnelle
le contrat d'apprentissage est donc un
dispositif très intéressant car il
permet de finir ses études avec de
l'expérience professionnelle
virginie est bien consciente de la
valeur de ce contrat
alors le contrat d'apprentissage est
pour moi un levier d'insertion
professionnelle c'est également un
ticket donc pour l'accès à une formation
professionnalisant dont qui permet
d'élargir nos connaissances et surtout
d'acquérir de nouvelles compétences sur
le lieu de travail j'ai décidé de faire
mon contrat d'apprentissage au sein du
conseil général car j'ai déjà effectué
un stage en début d'année dans le cadre
de ma licence en gestion des entreprises
qui s'est très bien passé aussi il faut
rajouter que c'est ici sur l'île donc ça
me permet de rester près de ma famille
de mes proches c'est également une
grosse collectivité qui gère plus de
5000 agents donc dans le domaine des
ressources humaines c'est très
enrichissant en termes de connaissance
les deux compétences à acquérir
donc à terme après la réussite de mon
diplôme dont j'aimerais intégrer une
entreprise publique ou privée sur la
dépense mais j'aimerais rester dans le
domaine des ressources humaines afin de
pouvoir m'épanouir professionnellement
aussi j'aimerais rester sur l'île
pourquoi tout simplement parce que j'ai
des projets professionnels et cela me
permettrait d'allier vie privée vie
professionnelle tout en gardant le
sourire comme virginie beaucoup de
jeunes réunionnais veulent réussir et
s'épanouir professionnellement un
objectif ordinaire mais compliqué à
notre époque à cause des difficultés que
rencontrent les entreprises qu'elles
soient privées ou publiques les
entreprises s'efforcent de participer à
cette démarche en intégrant des contrats
d'apprentissage au sein de leur équipe
le département est très impliqué dans ce
domaine chaque année beaucoup de
contrats d'apprentissage sont signés au
conseil général une démarche solidaire
visant à soutenir et à aider la jeunesse
réunionnaise
le contrat d'apprentissage est partie de
la politique volontariste du conseil
général en attire du public jeune
pour autant il ya aussi d'autres
dispositifs avec le pack jeune la
mobilité avec le tarn la volonté du
conseil général de financer plus de 750
emplois d'avenir dont 250
en direct
le parcours de l'insertion
professionnelle
que ce soit au niveau de la formation
que ce soit en termes de contrats aidés
donc ça démontre bien que la volonté du
conseil général en tout cas d'aidé ce
public jeune le contrat d'apprentissage
est une expérience formidable pour nos
jeunes puisque tant au niveau théorique
et pratique
il y avoue cette expérience qui
permettra justement à nos jeunes
plus tard et bien d'avoir
une expérience très fortes dans son
parcours professionnel ce qu'il faut se
dire c'est que
nous avons quand même un taux de
réussite de plus de 66% donc ce qui
conforte notre choix d'accentuer en tout
cas ce dispositif puisque depuis 2006
jusqu'aujourd'hui plus de 500 contrats
d'apprentissage ont été signés et pour
la seule année 2013 plus de 100 contrats
étaient signés donc ça démontre bien la
volonté du conseil général en tout cas
de s'inscrire dans cette démarche ce
sont les étudiants d'aujourd'hui qui
feront l'arrêt on de demain le conseil
général tient à ce que notre département
continue de soutenir nos cadets et fait
le nécessaire pour que la jeunesse
réunionnaise est une bonne situation
professionnelle car c'est un facteur
indispensable au bon équilibre des
foyers et des familles dont ils seront
les acteurs le conseil général de la
réunion vous a présenté lien social le
conseil général aux côtés des
réunionnais